The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: All
right, we're going
to continue talking
about convolutional code.
So I want to give you a quick
reminder of how coding works
and then talk to
you about decoding.
Can you hear me OK now?
All right?
OK.
So we talked in terms
of a state diagram,
but let me remind you of the
shift register picture was.
So we had a two-stage
shift register.
For this particular
example, we had xn, a stream
of data being fed in here.
So since this is
a shift register,
what sits in here at time
n is the previous input.
What sits here is the
input from 2 times ago.
And you can then feed these
off and get your parity check.
So take these in
particular combinations
and make your parity checks.
So you can have one box
spitting out a p0 of n.
And then you can
have another box
that takes these same outputs
from the shift register
and puts out--
let me just show them.
Actually, why don't
I just put it here?
You generate a bunch
of party check bits.
And I've shown an
example on top where--
this is the same one
I used last time.
p0 at time n--
I should have had an n there--
is xn plus xn minus
1 plus xn minus 2.
And p1, xn, and at xn minus 2.
And we skip the xn minus 1.
But you can choose different
coefficients there.
Different coefficients
will give you
codes that have
different properties.
So the choices in the code are
how many shift registers do
you have, so how much memory.
The constraint length
here is equal to what?
Constraint length in
this particular example
on the slide?
AUDIENCE: 3.
PROFESSOR: k equals 3?
Oh, you can see it.
It's the number of
message bits that
are involved in generating
a parity bit at the maximum.
It's actually not the number.
It's the window
over which you're
taking message bits to combine
to make the parity bits.
All right, so for instance,
if you just had p1,
you would still say that
your constraint length is 3,
because you're involving a
window of three message bits.
It's the span over
which you're extending.
All right, now, in terms
of interpreting this,
we've got the possible states of
the shift register combination.
So 0, 0; 0, 1' 1, 0' 1, 1, these
are the four possible states.
So in general, what you have
is for a constraint length k,
you've got 2 to the k minus 1
states, because one of these
is the input.
And then the other
is stored in memory.
So you've got k minus
1 stored in memory.
So that's the number of
states that you have.
And that's how these
circles are labeled here.
And then on each of
the arcs, what you have
is the message bit that's coming
in at that time and the parity
bits that are emitted.
So for instance, from 0,
0, if you've got 0 here
and 0 here, the only places
you can go to at the next step
are 0, 0, and 0, 1,
because you can either--
sorry, 0, 0 and 1, 0,
because you can either
feet in a 0 or a 1 from here.
If you feed in a 0, then at the
next state, you're still in 0.
If you feed in a 1, then at
the next state, you're 1, 0.
So those are the only
possibilities from 0, 0.
And if you had a 1 in, you
would go from 0, 0 to 1, 0.
And what would be your
parity check bits?
So if you had 1 at
the input and you
have the parity
check expressions
that I have up here, you see
that what you would be emitting
would be a 1 and a 1.
Is that right?
If you had a 1 in
the input, 0, 0,
and you use these two parity
bits, you generate a 1 and a 1.
So that's how these
arcs are labeled.
Now we said, to
actually understand
the convolutional code
well, what you really
want to do is translate
the state transition
diagram to a trellis diagram.
This is just showing two
stages of the trellis.
In general, the trellis
would be the state diagram
unfolded over the whole
time interval of interest.
So it's the same thing.
It's just that we've--
let's see.
We've chosen to write the
states in binary counting order,
so 0, 0; 0, 1; 1, 0; 1, 1.
It was arranged slightly
differently here.
Apart from that,
it's the same thing.
So we're drawing the
state diagram here.
We're drawing the
same state diagram
here except this is representing
the state possibilities
at time--
at one particular time.
And this is the
state possibilities
of the next particular time.
So the state transition
arrows are always
going from one stage
to the next, all right?
So the arrow that we
saw here, which takes us
from 0, 0 to 1, 0
is going to take us
from this box to this box.
And what it emits on the
way is the 1 and the--
sorry, the 1, 1.
What it emits is the 1, 1.
So each arc is labeled
in the same way.
This is just a rearrangement.
Now, the nice thing I mentioned
last time, the nice thing
about this is, when you have
this in binary counting order,
then the upper arc of the two
that emanate from each box
corresponds to an input of 0.
The lower arc corresponds
to an input of 1.
So you can actually
dispense with the index
or with the bit that's in
front of the stroke there.
So you can just make do with
labeling by the parity bits.
So you'll get used to that.
0 is the upward movement.
And 1 is a downward movement.
So if you're thinking
at the transmitter--
by the way, I hope I've
made these changes well.
I had an earlier
version of this slide,
but I changed it to work for a
new set of parity bits, which
meant I had to go in and change
every one of these transitions.
So you might see the
odd bug here and there.
But hopefully this is
correct and consistent
with the state transition
diagram I showed you.
So what we're saying
is now suppose you're
starting off in the 0, 0 state.
And you get the sequence
of message bits.
So 0, 1, 1, 1 is your message.
And then you bring it back to
the 0 state again by appending
two 0's.
What's the path that you
traverse through the trellis?
Well, you're starting
off in the 0 state.
Every time you have
a 0 in the message,
you take the upper branch.
Whenever you have a 1, you take
the lower branch of the two
that are available to you.
So you can see very
quickly how to steer
through this trellis for any
particular message sequence.
So this is the upper
one of the two here,
and then the lower one of the
two here because it's a 1,
then the lower one of the
and the lower one of the two
here because it's a 1, and then
the upper one because it's
a 0, and the upper one
because it's a 0.
So that's your path
through the trellis.
It's told to you by
the message bits.
You should also remember,
by the way, this diagram
hides a little bit, because
I have just a box here
for something that's
actually a pair of registers.
So when I just show the box,
let's say, at this point,
this actually has the 1
and the 0 sitting in it.
So if you were just looking at
this box and what was in it,
if I just gave you the
contents of that box,
could you tell me what the
input was of the previous time?
If I just told you that
the contents of that box
are 1 and 0, can you
tell me what the input
was at the previous time?
Yes?
It's just what
got fed in, right?
It's just the one
that got fed in.
So this diagram
is fine, but we've
suppressed a little bit there.
There are occasions, especially
on homework and quiz problems,
where you're given the contents
of the shift registers.
And you're asked to figure out
what happened at the last time
step, what message bit came in.
So really, don't
forget that there
is a link between the two.
OK, so the steering
is straightforward.
Now, what's the code
word that's emitted?
Well, it's the parity bits
that you encounter on the arcs.
So on this upper
arc here, you've
got a 0, 0 that's emitted.
So that's what
you're going to emit.
That's the part of the code word
generated by that message bit.
And then on the lower
arc, you emit 1, 1.
On the lower arc, you
emit 0, 1, lower arc,
you emit 1, 0, and
0, 1, and then 1, 1.
So that's the code word.
So the set of all
possible code words
that you can get with
this convolutional code
corresponds to the
set of all paths you
can take through the trellis.
If you're starting
at 0, 0, 0, then it's
the set of all paths
starting at 0, 0, 0.
So let's see.
Roughly speaking, can you tell
me, if I've got l stages--
when I say stages,
I mean time, if you
want to think of these
as happening on a clock.
If I've got l stages here and
I'm starting off with the 0
state there, for a large l,
roughly how many possible paths
do I have?
Any thoughts?
2 to the l?
Yeah.
Because you see here, coming
out of a box here on each stage,
you've got two choices.
And you've got those two
choices for l stages.
So you've got approximately
2 to the l possible paths.
Now, I say approximately,
because well, in this case,
it's fine.
But now if you're a lot to start
from other starting states,
then you will have to
take account of that.
But it's of that order.
It's exponential.
The number of possible
paths that you can have,
the number of code words is
exponential in the length
of the trellis, right?
OK, so that's a large
number of code words.
Our focus, though, is going
to be on decoding today.
What I did so far was just
review what we saw for coding.
We're interested
in decoding now.
So at the receiver, what you
have is a knowledge of what
the code is.
So you have the trellis.
You know what the labels are.
You know that things are going
to start in the zero state.
And then you get
your received signal.
Now, what I've shown
here is that, actually,
your received signal is
not necessarily going to be
0's and 1's.
It's probably going to be
samples of some voltage, where
you've got some waveform.
You process it.
And then you take a sample.
And what you've got is a
sample of some voltage.
So you're typically
looking at real numbers
that you then have to decide
whether to call as a 0 or a 1.
OK, so yeah, maybe this is 0,
0, maybe 0, 1; 0, 1, probably 1,
0; 0, 1; 1, 0, yeah?
So if you were forced to choose,
if you had a threshold of 0.5,
for instance, and this was
the range, if nominally
these were supposed
to be at 0 and 1,
then you might actually
be willing to call
this one way or another.
So if I was to draw
this on the real axis
thinking of a voltage, so
we've got 0 volts that we're
expecting, 1 volt or
something proportional to 1
volt that we're expecting.
These are the two possible
values depending on
whether a 0 is sent
or a 1 is sent.
This is because
we've coded the bits
at the transmitter for
physical transmission
on a continuous time channel.
And then at the receiving end,
we're doing some processing
and extracting samples, right?
But because of noise,
what might happen
is that you get samples
anywhere around the 0
or anywhere around
the 1, depending
on the particular
transmission instance.
It'll vary from one
instant to the next.
And if the noise is really
bad, then of course,
what started off as a
0 here with the noise
added to it, by the
time you sample it,
might fall in a region
where you call it a 1.
So there is an
intermediate step.
And very often, you
have access to that.
And then you've got to figure
out how to do your decoding.
All right, is this
the same slide?
Or does it say
anything different?
OK.
So what are we going to do now?
We're going to, of all
the paths available to us,
we're going to try and
find the path along which
the emitted parity bits
come closest, in some sense,
to the sequence of samples here.
That's, if you were
doing minimum distance,
in some sense, that's
what you'd want to do.
If you believed that
errors further away from 0
are less likely than
errors close to 0,
then you would want to have
a reconstructed set of parity
bits along whatever
path you choose
to come close to
the values there.
Now, it turns out that
it's actually simpler
initially to think of
first making a decision
to call these 0's or
1's and then finding
a path through this that
comes closest to the 0, 1
sequence that approximates
the voltage samples
that you've actually got.
So we make a distinction
between what's
called hard decision decoding
and soft decision decoding.
So in soft decision decoding,
which we'll talk about later,
you preserve those
voltage samples.
And you don't mess with them.
But in hard decision
decoding, at each stage,
you just make a
decision, on each sample,
decide to call it a 0 or a
1 and proceed from there.
OK, so which do you think
is likely to get you
better performance
if you're doing
the optimal thing after that?
AUDIENCE: Soft.
PROFESSOR: The soft?
Yeah.
Because when you make the
decision at one stage,
you're throwing away
some information.
You're not taking account
of how these samples might
relate to each other.
You're treating that
sample in isolation.
If you know that what
you're going to end up with
is a code word that corresponds
to a path through here,
then there is
additional information
that actually couples the
different numbers you're
getting across there.
And so you have a
hope of doing better
with soft decision decoding.
So postpone the
decision until later.
But you pay a cost.
Or you could pay a cost
for that, because you've
got to deal, for instance,
with the real numbers and all
of that.
So hard decision decoding
can simplify your processing.
So what you'll say is, I'll
just make a choice here.
So I'll call this 0, 0;
0, 1; 0, 1, and so on,
and then look for a path
through the Trellis along which
the emitted party
bits come closest
to what I've approximated
that sequence of samples by.
So we're talking about
having distance again.
And minimum timing distance
is going to give us the most
likely path, given that
you've already committed
to interpreting the received
samples as 0's or 1's.
So what you might
imagine is, OK, you've
got this received sequence.
You've got a tabulation
of all the possible paths
through the trellis and
the parity bits that
are emitted along those paths.
Each path corresponds
to a different message.
What you actually
have here-- let's see.
We've got 12 bits here, because
in addition to the message,
I'm appending a 0, 0 to each
one, which forces the trellis
back down to the 0 state.
So what I'm actually
doing here is,
I actually have a message
that's this followed by two 0's.
And so if you're trying
to connect these two
columns with the trellis that
I had on the previous page,
that's how you should
think about it.
But with any particular message,
you navigate up and down
on the trellis.
This particular one, you
navigate up, up, down, up.
And that's the sequence
that's generated.
That's the code
word that you would
expect if this was the message.
What you'll do is you'll
search over all possibilities.
At least that's one way
to do this, in principle,
search over all possibilities
for the code word
here that's closest
to what you received.
The trouble is, that's
a lot of code words.
That's a lot of code words.
So this can quickly
get out of hand.
If you've got long
sequences, which
is exactly where you want
to do convolutional coding,
you've got a very long table.
So you really want to
find an efficient way
to do this matching.
I just wrote down
the Hamming distance
that happens to hold for what
is the message that was actually
sent, which also will be the
message that you will recover
at the receiver if you
do the optimal thing
and you don't get
fooled by the errors.
So what I've got here as a
2 is the Hamming distance
between the code word here
and the received message.
So if that 2 was the smallest
one in that whole stack--
I haven't filled them all out--
then that's the one
that you would call.
OK, so a much
cleverer way of doing
this was invented
by the Viterbi,
who did his bachelor's
degree here,
then moved to the West Coast.
He was very involved
in the JPL program.
But he was also a
founder of, well,
a succession of companies,
but most recently, Qualcomm.
And he's a big friend
of the department.
He's on our visiting committee.
Or he has served time with
the visiting committee.
So this is an algorithm that
he developed in the early days.
And we're going
to talk about it.
I think I'll put it
all up on the slide.
And then let's talk.
All right, there is a lot there.
I don't want you to
struggle through that.
Let's talk about it here.
And when we're
done, I think what's
up there will make sense.
That's for you to refer
to from the slides later.
And it's my little
checklist to know
that I've spoken
about everything,
but don't try and
navigate that just yet.
So here is what Viterbi says.
He says, we're starting off
from some initial state.
This is the zero state.
At an intermediate state,
intermediate time--
sorry, I shouldn't say state.
I meant stage or time.
At an intermediate stage, we
have these four possibilities.
What I'm going to do for a
given received sequence--
and let me actually put
the received sequence
I'm going to use
in this example.
We've got a received sequence.
Let's say it's 0, 0 on
the first stage, and then
0, 1 on the second
stage, and 0, 1; 1, 0--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Yeah?
Did someone say something?
No?
I thought I heard--
OK.
We'll park the question for
now and check in again later.
OK, here is the
received sequence.
What we're trying to do is
find a path through the trellis
where the emitted
bits come closest
to this in Hamming distance.
Here is what Viterbi
proposes to do.
He says, from the
starting state,
let's find the
optimum path to each
of these states at
any particular time,
let's say a time i here.
Here is time i.
Let's find the
optimum path to these
with the associated
minimum cost.
So let's assume
that I have that.
So what I'm going to do
is, for each of these,
I'm going to put in some number.
This won't be
exactly the notation
that we have on this slide,
but it's streamlined.
These p's correspond to
what we call path metrics.
And I should actually
have an index i here
to tell you that I'm
doing this at time i,
but I'll just leave that off.
p sub 1 is cost along
optimal path to state one.
OK, so assume that,
magically, you've
computed the
optimal path to this
starting from the initial time.
So what that means is
maybe you've gone down
to a particular stage here.
You've gone down further.
And then maybe
you've come up here.
Maybe that's the optimum path.
So what you're
going to keep track
of is, for each of
these times, for each
of these states, what's
the cost, the optimal cost?
Or what's the cost along
an optimal path there?
OK, now what do I mean by cost?
I just mean Hamming
distance between what
I received and the
parity bits emitted along
the way up to that point.
So Viterbi is going to keep
track of this for every stage
as you step along and for
every one of these states.
Now, let's take
this particular one.
If I'm transitioning to
state one here, let's see.
This emits a 0, 0 if I go from--
let's go back to our trellis.
I should draw this up, actually.
But if I go along the
top, I am at 0, 0.
What other state comes
into the top one?
This comes in.
And this emits 1, 1.
So what's the cost I incurred
if I take the upper path?
The cost is just the Hamming
distance between the 1, 0
that I received and the
0, 0 that I have here.
So there is a cost of 1.
Let me, again, use
colors for costs here.
What's the cost I
incur if I instead
come to this point from
p2, again cost of 1?
So this is the generic picture.
What you're going to do
is, you're having this--
you have this at any stage.
You compute the branch
costs and continues.
And now suppose p1 was equal
to 3 and p2 was equal to 4,
and you wanted to figure out
what's the shortest way, what's
the minimum-cost way to get
from the origin to this point,
to p1 at the next time instant?
What's the minimum cost?
And what's the root?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: If you
came from here,
you've incurred a cost
of 3 up to this point.
And you're adding an
additional cost of 1.
You'll end up with a
cost of 4 to get to here.
If you get to hear
from p2, well, you've
incurred a cost of, let's
say, 4 up to this point.
And now you're going to
incur an additional cost
to bring it to 5.
So your best route
to p1 at this time
is to come from p1 at
this time using this arc.
So if you've built it up
at a particular stage,
then it's actually
very straightforward
to figure out what you
should do at the next stage.
So let me now start putting
some time indices on this.
This would be p1 at
time i is equal to 3.
p1 at time i plus
1 is equal to 4.
This is p2 at time i.
So you can actually
forget about this arrow,
because there is no way you're
going to use that arrow.
Whenever you come to
this stage at this time,
you're going to come
via the upper branch.
So at every stage,
you're going to do this.
And it's a very
simple calculation.
So now we've got slightly
more elaborate notation up
on the board, but I hope
you have the general idea.
This is an instance,
by the way, and a way
of thinking about such
problems that's referred
to as dynamic programming.
It works for these sorts
of rooting problems.
We're rooting ourselves
along a trellis where
the total cost of
taking a path is the sum
of the costs at every stage.
So the total Hamming
distance between the bits
you emit along the way and
the bits that you've received
is made up of the Hamming
distance between the branch
here and the piece
you've received here
plus the Hamming distance on the
branch here plus the piece you
between the branch
here and the branch--
sorry, the received segment
over there, and so on.
So the total Hamming
distance is made up
of the sum of the Hamming
distances along the way.
In all such situations where
you've got a total cost that's
additive over the
path and you've
got to do an optimization,
dynamic programming
is something you can think of.
And the idea we've used
here is actually one
that you might
come at naturally.
If you found the best way from
here to the Student Center,
and it happens to
go through Lobby 7,
what's your best way
from here to Lobby 7?
Presumably, it's going to
be the section of the path
that you would take to
the Student Center that
passes through Lobby 7,
because if you had a better way
to get to Lobby
7, you would have
used it to get to the
Student Center via Lobby 7.
It's just that idea.
So on an optimum path where
the costs are additive,
it must be the case
that the optimum path
to an intermediate
point is exactly
the section of the
optimum path to the point
that you're looking
at, a simple idea.
OK, so let's go back
to the more formal way
it's written up
here on the slide.
So we talk about
the branch metric.
That's just the Hamming
distance that we computed here
for the branch.
It's the difference
between what we received
and what would be transmitted
if you moved along that arc.
So that's the branch metric.
It's the piece
contributed by the branch.
This is the notation we've used.
We've already talked about this,
that you could either do a hard
decision kind of rule where
you've already set these
to 1's and 0's.
Or you could stick with
the original samples.
If you've already converted
them to 1's and 0's, there
is a natural notion of distance,
which is the Hamming distance.
And there is a
probabilistic reason
why you would want to do that.
So we're sticking to
the Hamming distance
setting right now, so
hard decision decoding.
And the path metric, this
is a more elaborate notation
than what I have here.
So instead of a subscript
to denote the state,
this has got the state index
here, and the time index here,
and pm for path metric
instead of just p,
but it's the same thing.
So for each state
and at each stage,
so for each of the four states
and for each of the stages,
you're going to compute this.
And you can the path
metric up to time
i is the smallest
sum of the branch
metrics over all
the sequences that
will get you to that place.
And if you assume you
have that at any stage,
then the computation that
takes you to the next stage
is an easy one.
I think I've said all this.
You can come back to it later.
So let's actually just
step through this.
So we're at some
intermediate stage.
We're just doing the same
thing I had on the board.
I'm doing it again
in pictures here
so you get to think
about it one more time.
Suppose we've received 0, 0.
We first label each of the arcs
here by the Hamming distance
between the bits we'd emit
along the arc and the bits
we've actually received,
so Hamming distant 0 here
between what we would
emit and what we received,
Hamming distance 2 here on
this arc, Hamming distance
2 on this arc, and so on.
So the red numbers here
are below the top two
just are the costs on the arcs.
Actually, I don't like the
last line of that slide.
So you may want to strike that.
We're not going to really
be talking about the most
likely branch metric.
We're only going to make
decisions once we're
done with the whole path.
So we assume at some stage,
that we have the path metrics
up to that point.
And then we do the computation
that I just talked about.
So let's see.
In this particular case, what
would be the path metric value
in this position?
It's the same thing
we did already,
but just another
chance to look at it.
What would be the value
of the path metric there?
3?
Because you can either
do 3 plus 1 on that arc.
Or you can do 2 plus 1
on this-- sorry, 3 plus 1
on this arc for a
cost of 4 or 2 plus 1
on this arc for a cost of 3.
So it should be a 3 there.
And this is the arc
that you would pick.
And similarly, you can
do it for all of them.
So once you have one stage,
you can fill out the next stage
completely and then keep
track of the arcs that
lead you there.
And at some point, you'll--
at each stage, actually,
you can prune away things that
you're not going to be using.
So you're never going
to use that edge.
So you don't have to
worry about it anymore.
You're never going
to use this edge.
There are also stages
where you might
have two different ways
of getting to a box
and incurring the same cost.
And then it doesn't matter
which of them you pick.
You can pick one or the other.
In terms of the overall cost,
it's not going to matter.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Yeah, so
what you're saying
is that, if there isn't
a unique way back,
then you're not certain.
Well, you're never certain
here in this business.
You're just doing
your best guess.
So what you would do when you
commit to one particular choice
when there are two equally
likely costs is you're saying,
the probability
of error is going
to be the same with
this choice as it
will be with the other choice.
And in the end, that's what
we have for the metric.
It is unsatisfying, perhaps.
Now, there are
schemes where you'd
keep a list of the possibilities
and try and do something
with that, because maybe there
is some higher level thing that
would help you disambiguate
between possibilities,
but that would complicate
the processing.
But as far as this
goes, you make a choice.
And you move on.
So you can imagine
actually working
through this whole thing.
If you knew you were
starting from the zero state,
you'd start off with
a zero cost there.
So you're at
infinity here, which
is going to force all the
optimal paths to come from 0.
And then you'll
continue from there.
So I just wanted to show you a
few things that come with this.
Actually, I might have shown
you everything I want on that.
So let's just go back to
the soft decision decoding.
So how might things
differ if you go back
to soft decision decoding?
So let me find that slide.
The Viterbi algorithm
doesn't care
how you come at these costs.
The Viterbi algorithm is
just dynamic programming
on this trellis.
It finds you the
minimum-cost path.
It's up to you how
you decide what
cost to attribute to an edge.
So the question is, are
there other costs that you
might have come up with?
Well, if the received sequence
has been translated already
to 0's and 1's, then Hamming
distance is the natural thing.
But if you're keeping
particular numbers there,
then it turns out that you might
want to do things differently.
So suppose at a particular
stage, what you got was not--
let's see.
Did I put numbers up there?
Suppose it wasn't 0 and 1, but
it was some particular numbers,
let's say, 0.3 and 0.7.
And you had actually
translated them to a 0 and a 1
in your hard decision decoding.
If you decide not to
do that, but to stick
with these numbers,
then what you
have is the task for
any particular edge
that you're traveling
on of finding
the distance between
the parity bits
you would emit on that edge and
the samples that you have here.
It turns out that a very widely
used cost for soft decision
decoding is the sum of
squared differences.
So what you would
have is 1 minus 0.3
squared plus 1
minus 0.7 squared.
So it would be the
first bit that you
emit on this arc
minus the first sample
that you got squared error
plus the second sample,
the second bit
that you would emit
on this arc minus the second
sample, whole thing squared.
If there was another arc
that was a 1 and 0 arc,
then what you would
computers 1 minus 0.3
squared plus 0
minus 0.7 squared.
So it's just a different way
of coming up with the cost.
The rest of the Viterbi
algorithm is exactly the same.
the navigating through the
trellis is exactly the same.
It turns out that there
is a logic and a reason
behind this particular
metric for situations where
your voltage samples
are distributed
in the familiar
bell-shaped fashion here,
what's called a
Gaussian distribution.
We'll talk about
it more next time.
So what we're saying is
that if you send a 1,
you get a spread
of possible values.
The probability of
your values falling
in some particular range here
can be computed by the area
under this particular curve.
It's got an
analytical expression.
So this is the most likely spot.
But there is certainly
probabilities
of falling in any
particular interval here.
Well, what does the Gaussian
distribution look like?
We'll talk more about it.
the essential part of
it is e to the minus--
let's see.
Let me put some labels here.
This is where it's centered.
Let me call it mu.
And let's say x is the
value along the axis.
So we'll have e
to the x minus mu
all squared divided by
some normalizing parameter.
Well actually,
let's just call it
capital N. Think of capital
N as a noise variance.
Actually, let me
just call it N sub 0
so you don't think
it's a counting number.
Think of it as a noise variance.
So the larger that
N is, would you
spread out more or less here?
Well, just from the fact
that I call it a variance,
maybe you would guess
that, if N is larger,
you're going to spread out more.
Well, in this kind of setting,
when you take log likelihoods--
you've seen that computation
in the chapters--
what ends up appearing
in your cost criterion
is x minus mu squared.
So it's the squared
difference from the mean
that you want to be looking at.
And that's exactly why,
in that kind of setting,
this is what you end up
choosing as your cost metric.
But once you're done
computing those metrics,
the rest of the Viterbi
algorithm is the same.
So once you have the
convolutional coding in hand,
you know how to
decode, you can start
to do some comparisons of how
these different codes perform.
There is an extensive
discussion in the chapter.
Let me just give you
some highlights here.
OK, so what are
we plotting here?
What we're saying is we send
a whole bunch of message bits
through the channel.
And then we decode
at the other end.
And what we're
talking about is--
let's see.
Here is the binary
symmetric channel.
Here is the error
probability on the channel.
You can see to well what
this is, but it's the--
why is that chopped off?
It's the probability of
error overall end to end,
not of the channel,
but after you've
done your coding and decoding.
Let's see.
Do we recognize
any of these codes?
Here is the uncoded case
where basically you're
exposing the stream directly
to the error on the binary
symmetric channel.
We expect higher
errors when we have
higher probabilities of
flipping a bit on the channel.
So this is the uncoded case.
What does the Hamming code do?
That's a Hamming code
probability, 0.74.
So the Hamming code
performance, you can see here
end to end what it looks like.
What's the rate
that goes with that?
What's the rate of
that Hamming code?
4 over 7, right?
Because n is the number
of bits in the message--
sorry, in the code word.
And 4 is the number of bits
in the message, so 4 over 7,
something over 1/2.
Let's see.
Do we know what
that code might be?
Any codes you know about
that take 4 message bits
and pad them to
8 code word bits?
You've seen at
least one such code.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Sorry?
AUDIENCE: Rectangular parity?
PROFESSOR: Rectangular
parity, right?
If you didn't have
that corner parity bit,
but you just did the
rows and columns,
then you'd arrange 4
bits in a 2 by 2 pattern
and then have 4 parity bits.
So that's a rectangular parity.
That's rate 1/2.
What this denotes is
a convolutional code.
It's actually the
code we've been--
sorry, no, this one is the
code we've been looking at.
So let me explain to you
what that notation means when
you're reading the chapter.
This code is represented as--
the one we've been talking
about as represented as this.
So what this is is
the constraint length.
And what this is
is just to tell me
that the generator bits I
used for my party generation
correspond to the binary
representation of 7
and the binary
representation of 5.
So remember that for
my first parody bit,
I chose xn plus xn
minus 1 plus xn minus 2.
I picked all three of them.
For my second parity bit,
I took xn plus xn minus 2.
I skipped the middle one.
So the notation that's used
to denote a convolutional code
with these two generators is,
just for compactness, the 7,
5 there.
Let's see.
Is this redundant,
the k, the value of k?
Could you have figured out
what the constraint length is?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
It's already staring at you here
what the constraints length.
So this is a little redundant.
It's just that it's
a convenient way
to distinguish a convolutional
code from a Hamming code.
Now, we have to be a little
careful comparing these codes,
because the rates are
all a little different.
Here the rate is 1/2.
What's the rate for
this convolution
for the two convolution
codes here, the 3, 7, 6
and the 3, 7, 5?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Sorry, what's--
AUDIENCE: 1/2 [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: 1/2, right?
So the rate is 1 over
the number of parity bits
you're generating per message.
One message bit, r parity bits,
therefore, a rate of 1 over r.
So these are rate one-off codes,
just like the rectangular case.
This is constraint length 4.
And you can actually write
out what that would be there.
How big is the trellis for
the constraint length 4 case?
How many stages?
This last one down there?
8, right?
Constraint length 4, that means
k equals 4, 2 to the k minus 1,
so 2 cubed states.
So there is 8 states
that we're talking about.
The Cassini convolution code
that I showed you last time
had a constraint length of 15.
So how many states
there on the trellis?
2 to the 14, that's
a lot of states.
So that's a lot of
computation there happening.
And actually, there
is no hope of that
having been done if it wasn't
for the Viterbi algorithm.
All right, we'll talk more about
comparison between these codes
next time.
Sorry, I should do
one more thing here.
I did talk last time about
this notion of free distance.
Let's just stare
at this a second.
We said the free distance was
the weight of the smallest
non-zero codeword.
And it gave you a handle on
the performance of the code.
It was the Hamming distance
for the set of code words
you could generate between
0, 0 here and 0, 0 there.
Can you see by inspection
here what might be a candidate
free distance here?
I think what we had
last time was 5, right?
This is the 1, 1; 0, 1; 1, 1.
And we'll pick up 1, 2,
3, 4, 5, a weight of 5.
And it turns out there is no
other path that's smaller.
So the performance of
this particular code
is indicated by that number 5.
It tells you that you
can correct two bits.
But actually, it
tells you much more
than you would typically try
and extract from a typical block
code where you would say, if
there is Hamming distance 5,
you only can correct two codes.
Here you've got
message bits that
go on for a long time,
thousands of bits.
So what this is telling you
is that in a duration that's
of the order of five
or six message bits,
you can, with this scheme,
correct up to two bits.
You can have bursts of
errors that are very frequent
and correct them with
this Viterbi decoding.
So the free distance
is an important notion.
So when you do the examples
in recitation tomorrow,
please look out for what the
free distance is for your codes
and compare with
what we have here.